I fell in love with cuphead almost
immediately its hand-drawn graphics
exude charm its ragtime soundtrack
propels the action forward and the
mechanics are as refined as any
platformer I've played and of course
cuphead is also incredibly difficult
drawing on running gun games such as
contra 3 or gun star heroes studio mvhr
prioritizes flawless jumping shooting
and dodging over anything else in
cuphead it's a gorgeous game but if
you've spent much time with it then you
know how brutal it can also be you can
fight a boss 25 times to no avail you
will probably die a lot you may narrowly
achieve victory only when you learn from
dozens of mistakes according to the
creator's themselves that was their
intention from the beginning in a recent
interview with veteran developer Warren
Spector cop heads Chad moldenhauer
described a basic tenet of the games
difficulty keep the mechanics simple
enough to grasp but with enough variance
and technique to allow player mastery
and expression and a sufficiently
skilled player should be able to
potentially defeat every challenge on
the first try no trial by death or cheap
hits in theory this makes sense cup had
amplifies your sense of victory through
tough but fair challenges and you'll
only reach the end through hard work
patience or skill but that's just the
thing when moldenhauer mentions a
sufficiently skilled player what does he
mean what's the metric for measuring
player ability who's to say that cuphead
will eventually click for everyone who
buys and plays it
[Music]
cuphead does provide the option to play
levels on a simple mode bosses have
fewer hit points and will actually skip
some of their attack sequences
altogether if bars less dexterous
players from seeing everything the game
has to offer
what's more you can't play the last ten
percent or so of cuphead if you haven't
beaten every previous boss on the
regular difficulty you can watch youtube
videos yes but you're not playing them
essentially koppad excludes you if you
can't reach the sufficient skill level
its creators intended I myself
thoroughly enjoy difficult games
I adore Dark Souls and blood-borne I
pour hours into XCOM 2 every week
cuphead itself is one of my favorite
games of 2017 but it does raise a few
loaded questions do developers oh it to
consumers to show them their entire game
no matter the player's skill level
should games be made so everyone can
enjoy them can a game be too difficult
for its own good this is a problem
inherent to video games as a medium
outside of ticket prices movies don't
usually bar you from seeing everything
they have to show museums don't test you
before each new exhibit and if you want
you can skip to the final page of the
next book you read most games however
require motor skills problem solving or
some combination of the two if you want
to see everything I don't have concrete
answers to all the questions that
cuphead raises but regardless the game
does spark an intriguing conversation so
I decided to look at how other games
handle difficulty how developers found
creative loopholes to the problem and
how some games turned the idea of
difficulty on its head entirely one of
the more notable examples is Resident
Evil 4 it secretly scales difficulty to
react to the player's skill level
survive longer kill more enemies take
less damage and the difficulty will
gradually ramp up but die several times
in a row and the game will remove
certain enemies the next time around or
lower enemy health the mechanic subtly
makes the game more challenging for
skilled players and more accessible for
those with a casual play style you
probably know about this dynamic
difficulty slider by now but at the time
of its 2005 release Capcom hadn't said a
word about this brilliant system it
wasn't touted and any press releases or
shown off at convention
as the story goes the first public
mention of it was in resident evil force
official strategy guide a year later
this is because Capcom knew the value of
hiding such a mechanic it empowers
players of every skill level it doesn't
shame you for doing poorly and it
doesn't let you waltz through if you're
doing well it's one of my favorite games
ever made for several reasons but the
sliding difficulty is chief among them
left for dead took a similar approach
developer valves famed director doesn't
just alter the types of zombies you'll
encounter or the placement of weapons
throughout each chapter it also alters
the visual effects character
communication and music based on player
status and placement this not only
creates unique pacing in each
playthrough but a particular tone as
well but as clever as these two systems
are they both are reactionary to the
players skill level they gauge your
ability and adjust accordingly in 2014
developer monolith took it a step
further rather than just react to your
performance why not incorporate it into
the story as well why not let the enemy
grow alongside you regardless of whether
you win or lose this idea gave rise to
the Nemesis system in Middle Earth
shadow of mordor enemy Oryx and orcs
developed grudges skills fears and
rivalries based on your encounters
Mayman or a captain and he'll have the
scars to show for it
flee from a fight with a powerful
opponent and they'll greet you later on
with taunts of cowardice different
players will develop their own personal
stories they'll seek revenge on
different captains grow to hate unique
orcs along the way last week's release
of the sequel shadow of war expands upon
this idea
it doesn't punish you for failing in
fact you could say it's actually more
enjoyable when you fail in fighting
dying and fighting again you create your
own stories with our own idiosyncratic
villains waiting at the end whereas
monoliths middle-earth series is about
adapting to failure with an immortal
character others force you to confront
the idea of actual loss two examples
immediately come to mind for access
games XCOM series and intelligent
systems Fire Emblem titles
although you do have the option to
disable it both games place permadeath
at the center of their design lose a
soldier to enemy fire and they're gone
forever
make a poor tactical decision and you
can't go back you make your choices you
try to learn from them you do your best
to move on both series understand that
respawning is a safety net by removing
that net the games become more tense but
also play with difficulty in a clever
way sending your best soldier into the
fray increases your chance for
short-term success but creates more
long-term risk as well if you lose that
soldier your whole team will suffer down
the road you'll need to build new
soldiers up from their beginnings as
green rookies to their decorated glory
days this transparent sort of dynamic
difficulty slider plays with it in a way
that few other games can
I can't talk about difficulty without
touching in some way on Dark Souls
anyone who has heard of from software's
third-person action games will know how
punishing they could be they're
notorious for colossal bosses and
abusive enemies if you don't reach the
next checkpoint you could lose all of
the experience you've fought so hard to
gain but despite their intimidating
challenge level the Dark Souls games and
their cousin blood-borne do provide
options to players who don't have the
same patience or skill as others certain
character classes make the earlier hours
easier while range classes can mitigate
the intensity of many battles throughout
the entire game furthermore developer
from software also provides options to
summon other human players to your cause
or specific NPCs that can help you along
the way the studio made these games
difficult on purpose but also knows that
not everyone wants to lower their
shoulders and charge through the fight
on their own some need company along the
way all of these games I've mentioned
have a common thread they acknowledge
that everyone plays games in different
ways for different reasons some play for
the challenge some play for the escapism
some play to catch up with friends or
just to unwind at the end of the day
some people are less dexterous than
others
some require specially made controllers
to accommodate for disabilities and of
course all of this is ok we're all still
having fun and this all leads back to
cuphead is it good game designed to bar
less skilled players from advancing to
the end of that game should developers
account for numerous play styles when
molding their visions or should they
focus on a smaller subset of people who
want a very specific experience
regardless of widespread accessibility
the larger more loaded question here is
nothing new it's the entire dilemma of
modern art is it defined by what the
Creator wants to convey or by what the
recipient takes from it
shortly after conversations arose
regarding cup hats difficulty rani
ishmael one half of the independent team
Vlambeer took to twitter to talk about
the conundrum of video game difficulty
he outlined the studio's philosophy with
its arcade shooter luftrausers and
described the process more eloquently
than I ever could a lot of people see
luftrausers as a game about difficulty
it isn't what matters to us is that to
you it is overwhelming in the face of
those overwhelming odds the game occurs
the difficulty is the backdrop the
gameplay a delivery method the goal is
Grace Luke Rogers is not about surviving
it's about cutting the engine after a
stall falling down guns blazing pulling
up right over the water
it's about bursting up from under water
through an exploding carrier straight
into impossible odds and a game over
just because it is cool